[Aplausos]
isto tá vendo
chama-se deus da água florestas comida
pássaros mais caras do texto do amor não
é a lagoa dos patos
ela gol dos deuses
as pessoas interpretaram lagoa dos patos
porque é uma palavra do momento na minha
mente
ao entrar neste paraíso não pode ser
lagoa dos patos mas sim lagoa dos deuses
eu vivo aqui eu falo contigo mais três
que respeitarem
sem isto não é de ninguém
sem isto sem isto não vivos
eu tive há setores da melhor que ouvia
as árvores a dançar viu o cintilar e das
águas a caírem nas rochas é maior sim
folia do mundo 1 no olímpico
love tem esta sinfonia da natureza
não há dinheiro para isto não há ouro
pra isto na um diamante pra isto
isso foi do mito vieste foi daqui tu
nasceste
lembrar há bilhões de anos atrás os
povos nascer numa imagem evento cai esta
água lama e terra selva árvores plantas
pássaros e daí procuramos os caminhos de
transformarmos aqmi que somos hoje é
defensor da natureza não é defensor da
natureza e defensor dos deuses da
natureza é sonae e aí é san justo que eu
quero que nós vamos em frente
não deixarem fazer reclamamos dizer
qualquer coisa que isto vocês nada isto
é minha alma e meu coração
este é um passo que carta dentro domingo
se tiver cinco minutos de silêncio tubos
tantas vozes tantas tantas bolas de
todas as línguas de tuas compreendemos
porque é porque é desigual esta natureza
porque é estudar o fruto é isto a nossa
árvore
isso é paixão está o amor e que os
postos dizer mais do que isto
não há palavras a emoção
isto foi a melhor medicina que eu tive
em toda em toda a minha vida eu já fui
durante um dia poder ao meu ver o mestre
como curar mas eu vou seguir os caminhos
eu hoje estou curado hoje sinto me livre
eu hoje som do pastor dos deuses dos
deuses sou laranjo que o processo siga
os passos dela
cada planta aspecto da terra elas bruxa
cresce
que tipo de planta e essa pode ser o
centeio como está o paulo a água
tubérculos de matar a sede e uma coisa
muito importante
um certo dia vem o senhor com o camelo
um veto carregava ouro tesouro
só que faltava algo
eu vinha todo preocupado todo cheias e
de cheia de fome e encontrou um
labirinto mais além
esse labirinto que é que eu tenho com
ela
água e paulo que tinha montouro de vice
eu dou tudo que eu tenho mas dá um
bocado paulo e uma pinguinha água e
através disso e só membro citou o que é
mais importante é isso que nos dá o
fruto ou é ou lucros traga ou é o outro
faz para comprar as armas ou é o ouro
faz com o período e faz a destruição eo
não
nós temos muito mais força do que isso
pode tirar tudo mas não lá machado que
corta o rio do pensamento nada nos
cortar as raízes da nossa mente porque
nasceu contínuo cespu puro é isto faz a
pureza não é o fumo não é casas feitas
de metal não é palco 12 das salas com 80
oitenta por cento da população mundial
com as obras só querem riqueza de
distribuições escolhem para isto
escolhe pré iii técnicos da alma é visto
que os meus eram é visto um deles vieram
e foi visto que o fruto e os frutos
alimentou a água corre foi água cruz
embalou e a partir daí brandas
nunca deixaremos talvez culpas terras
que está se recuperando assim os teus
avós ama o meu amor
a única coisa que eu mais uma paixoneta
é isto
isso é minha mulher e é minha mãe é o
meu pai e minha família
isso é o sonho vivo contigo a milhões de
índios em milhões de anos que existe
dentro de nós e essa é dna e vamos ter
sem pressa é ganhar dentro da nossas
mentes
porque é isso de s n a z
nós viemos a partir da quebrada deus
todos ou ver nos a compreender esta
fluidez chega sal itens em miami é um
produto iveco dos mais benéficas do ser
humano das flores que o cheiro a
hortência desde os passos que silva
região do bananal noite ser em tese o
pôr do sol que coisa mais linda que é
que nós temos temos tudo nós temos tudo
tudo tudo e não quero dinheiro quero
isto está mau e manta não é o dinheiro o
dinheiro economia
o dinheiro faz nós duas máquinas novas e
ciclagem ver só me faz mal isto ter umas
algemas do passado graças